mamadou cirelli quiero guarda esperanzas
su sueño canadiense se está esfumando y
tuve que pagar mucho dinero por el
papeleo y todo para ser rechazado
rotundamente y sin ninguna razón de peso
es realmente desalentador
tras 4 denegaciones de permisos de
estudio en dos años sus planes de
estudiar en una escuela canadiense se
están derrumbando y con ellos su futuro
en la pastelería
si estuviese en canadá y vuelves a tu
país a buscar trabajo te será fácil en
cualquier parte de áfrica cuanto más
tiempo esté aquí más difícil será para
mí estoy avanzando
mamá tu recibió una beca de quince mil
euros por parte de la provincia de
québec pero al igual que el al 70% de
los estudiantes africanos francófonos
que aplican para una visa el gobierno
canadiense se las niega en comparación
con el 35 por ciento de los estudiantes
no africanos
también te dicen que es porque no
planeas volver a tu país pero qué saben
ellos si realmente no quieren darte una
visa deberían decirte la verdadera razón
ante estas negaciones masivas un comité
federal examinó la cuestión tras un mes
de audiencia su informe es inapelable se
concluyó que algunas decisiones son
arbitrarias y que inmigración canadá no
facilita la llegada de estudiantes
africanos francófonos
y los funcionarios no deberían tener
prejuicios cuando empiezan a considerar
las solicitudes de los estudiantes la
solicitud debe ser evaluada como tal y
también recomendamos que hubiera un
mediador en el departamento de
inmigración para examinar la tasa de
denegación es
para hacer frente a estas elevadas tasas
de rechazo el comité permanente de
ciudadanía e inmigración formuló otras
34 recomendaciones
buenos días estoy bien gracias
la abogada de mamadou se muestra
pesimista las estadísticas para el año
2021 son abrumadoras de más de 77 mil
solicitudes de estudiantes de países
africanos francófonos alrededor de
53.000 fueron rechazadas por inmigración
canadá
podría estar perdiendo tiempo y dinero
se apuesta por ese proyecto de estudio
le recomendaría que optar a más por un
programa que le permite entrar como
trabajador extranjero temporal mediante
un empleo pero los rechazos anteriores
lo van a perjudicar así que tendrá que
trabajar mucho en el plan de retorno en
algunas de las aplicaciones que va a
presentar le deseo la mejor de las
suertes
la estrategia de canadá para atraer
inmigrantes está funcionando las
solicitudes de permisos de estudio
provenientes de todo el mundo casi se
han triplicado en siete años según
inmigración canadá la mayoría de los
estudiantes esperan obtener una visa
permanente
muchos tienen la impresión de ser
engañados por la publicidad sobre canadá
aquella en la que se les vende un sueño
que en la práctica no existe
un sueño incierto para los estudiantes
africanos que se ven obligados a
presentar un plan especialmente
detallado sobre el regreso a sus países
para un estudiante africano es realmente
un calvario porque tiene que demostrar
más que cualquier otro que su plan es
real es como si dieran por sentado que
se trata de una maniobra que actúan de
mala fe y que quieren quedarse en canadá
ese es el caso de muchas personas gente
que viene de europa de asia que tienen
el mismo sueño de venir a canadá
y canadá el programa informático sino
que también se encuentra en la mira de
la comisión este permite una tramitación
más rápida de las solicitudes de visa
pero resumen las candidaturas a 100
páginas en unas pocas líneas
y siempre recibimos las mismas negativas
no estoy convencido de que vaya a salir
de canadá al final de su periodo de
estancia dadas las escasas oportunidades
de empleo en su país de residencia dada
su situación laboral actual dada su
situación inmobiliaria y financiera lo
que nos preocupa es la falta de
transparencia del sistema y el hecho de
que no tengamos información real sobre
cómo se toma la decisión y cuando vemos
que los motivos de la denegación no
tienen ninguna relación con las pruebas
que se presentaron es muy muy
cuestionable
para la asociación le quede exentos y
quebec también somos nosotros en español
el informe federal llega en el momento
adecuado pues apoya su proyecto de ley
para la creación de un defensor de los
derechos de los inmigrantes el gobierno
tiene una cita con la historia se vio
obligado a admitir que existe un
problema y ahora el gobierno tiene
recomendaciones para ponerle fin o para
reducir el impacto de ciertas leyes de
inmigración sobre las personas
procedentes de áfrica
según el informe federal los estudiantes
africanos podrían ser víctimas de
prejuicios raciales al ser contactado
por france24 el ministerio de
inmigración reconoció que hay fallas en
su sistema pero estima que ya se han
hecho progresos sin embargo la
estrategia contra el racismo lanzada por
el gobierno de crudo en 2019 no habría
logrado frenar el racismo sistémico que
penaliza a los estudiantes africanos
hay formas de proceder formas de hacer
las cosas que a veces van en detrimento
de ciertos grupos eso es lo que lo hace
sistémico y por eso tenemos que
enfrentarnos a los mecanismos primero
hay que entenderlos hay que diseccionar
los hay que analizarlos y eso requiere
una revisión en profundidad
el ministerio de inmigración sigue
examinando las 35 recomendaciones del
comité federal se espera una respuesta
del gobierno en los próximos seis meses